in other news today a woman has been
found dead after a house was destroyed
in a gas explosion in birmingham
emergency services have been at the site
throughout the night following the blast
which happened yesterday evening one man
was rescued from the wreckage by
neighbors he remains in hospital in a
life-threatening condition uh we're live
in birmingham now our correspondent
becky johnson becky what more details do
we have at this stage
well really um teams here assessing um
how sound the buildings either side of
the house that exploded are if i just
step out of the way
you can see the extent of the
devastation caused by this gas explosion
last night
there was a three-bedroomed house in
that gap uh reduced now to a pile of
burnt rubble in amongst there there's
possessions there's furniture this
happened
instantaneously neighbors say they just
heard a very loud bang the ground shook
in fact some neighbors thought there was
a bomb or an earthquake or something and
then people came out into the street saw
this rubble on fire and then
many of the locals a group of around 10
young men being described as heroes
because they ran around the back and
actually went in and managed to pull
a severely injured man out of that
wreckage now he's in a critical
condition in hospital very sadly though
it's been confirmed that a woman who was
also in that house at the time has died
now several eyewitnesses to what
happened including one man kashif
mahmoud who i've been talking to he was
driving past so just on the road here
where all this debris is strewn he was
driving past at the time of the
explosion with his wife two young
children in the car
it completely the airbags of the car
went it blew all the glass out of the
windows and the sunroof they consider
themselves extremely lucky to have
escaped with just some minor cuts but
this is how he described what happened
to me
it's like you're driving and suddenly
you know it's like something happened
really really bad and all the airbag
came out and all the windows broken and
i thought something happened to the car
and
really really scary and shocking here
and then all the neighbors came out and
one of the lord he said there's somebody
in the house
and
and then next door not the house was
fully exploded next door and the one man
they took one man out a few large went
inside they took one man out and he was
injured
so a huge emergency service response as
you would expect and right now we've got
the urban search and rescue teams here
now they're assessing how stable this
whole
structure is behind us of course people
haven't been allowed back into these
houses it looks very unsafe windows
blown out
and also checking now we're told by
police they don't think
that there's anybody else in there but
of course they have to check
the the wreckage of the house just to
make sure
and we did have this update from the
area commander a short while ago from
west midlands fire service
our focus um in the in the sort of the
short term is to try and
reduce or minimize
any further impact
there's a lot of people who've been
displaced
within this road and within the
surrounding area and there's been a lot
of support from the communities so we'd
like to thank the communities for their
support but as you can see behind me um
there's now an investigation stage which
is taking place amongst a number of um
different sort of colleagues and
different services services to
understand exactly how this is uh how
this has taken uh taken place
so we know it was a gas explosion but
what they don't know at the moment is
the source of the explosion this house
had been up for sale and the particulars
of the house actually described how the
boiler would need repairing or replacing
so clearly that would be one line of
inquiry but at the moment
they're simply not sure how this
happened but as you can see um
completely demolished and of course the
next of kin of the woman who died being
contacted by police today with the very
sad news of what's happened